no fue un acto terrorista la policía de
waukesha wisconsin informó que el
sospechoso del atropello masivo estaba
huyendo de un incidente doméstico cuando
embistió a la multitud
el detenido quien conducía un
todoterreno rojo cuando derribó las
vallas del desfile navideño fue
identificado como dar ver brooks de 39
años tenemos información de que el
sospechoso antes del incidente estuvo
involucrado en un disturbio doméstico
tan sólo unos minutos antes el
sospechoso fue detenido a poca distancia
del lugar de los hechos y estamos
seguros de que actuó solo no hay pruebas
de que se trate de un incidente
terrorista el sospechoso enfrenta cinco
cargos de homicidio intencionado en
primer grado quien además podría pasar
el resto de su vida en la cárcel ya que
en wisconsin este tipo de delitos se
condena con cadena perpetua de las 48
personas heridas 18 niños fueron
atendidos en el hospital infantil de
boston sin algunos con presencia de
graves heridas 18 niños fueron traídos a
nuestro departamento de emergencia
infantil con edades comprendidas entre
los 3 y los 16 años las lesiones y van
desde abrasiones faciales hasta huesos
rotos y lesiones graves en la cabeza 6
de estos pacientes fueron enviados a la
sala de operaciones anoche y otros dos
pacientes están siendo operados hoy el
hospital también está presentando
servicios de salud mental a las víctimas
las familias y el personal
el presidente joe biden envió sus
condolencias a las familias de las
víctimas